if you want to know the changes you need
to make in your life so that you can
achieve your goals then this video is
for you
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world now I often get asked by
entrepreneurs who have all these goals
they have all these ambitions but
they're not actually taking action on it
and their goals are not being realized
and so in this video I'm going to talk
about the seven changes that you need to
make in your lifestyle so that you can
actually accomplish your goals way
number one is get super clear you have
to have an insane level of clarity over
what your goal is if you hope to
accomplish it a lot of people pick
really obscure goals so something like I
want to be rich well what is rich how do
you define rich I want to be successful
well success looks different for the
Dalai Lama as it does for Steve Jobs so
what does it look like for you if you
don't know where you're going then
you're going to continue to wander
aimlessly and so understanding what your
path is understanding what the finish
line is allows you to move towards it in
a much more effective manner so you need
to get super clear on your goals if it's
your big long-term vision for what you
want to accomplish as well as what
you're going to do tomorrow on your
schedule having clarity is power
[Music]
we number two is have a life goal and
immediate goals I'm a big fan of having
a big overall mission a huge goal that
you're trying to accomplish one that you
may never actually accomplish in your
lifetime so for me I believe that the
biggest problem the world is facing is
untapped human potential and that's a
problem I'm trying to solve I feel like
I'm solving or trying to solve the
world's biggest problem and I never will
actually ever fully solve it so it's a
constant drive it's a constant push for
me and it's the idea that the I think
was the Buddha that said you're trying
to empty the ocean with a ladle or with
a spoon and wake up every day and I try
to empty the ocean with a spoon that's
what I try to do like it's never gonna
happen but I'm gonna make progress every
single day I think having a big goal a
mission like that really helps you and I
think it's also really important to have
more immediate goals what am I gonna do
for the next three months what I'm going
to do for the next week what I'm gonna
do for the rest of today having that
clarity allows you to make progress so
matching up those immediate goals does
it lead me to accomplishing my big goal
yes or no and making sure that the
things that you write down on your
schedule are gonna match to your
ambition I feel a super-important and
also being really careful around what is
it that you are making your immediate
goals because if you set immediate goals
like I'm gonna make five youtube videos
this week I'm gonna make ten customer
calls this week I'm gonna finish this
flyer that I'm going to distribute out
I'm gonna create content from my social
media campaigns on all networks right
whatever your immediate goals are and
then you don't do them then you get used
to setting goals and not following
through and you start to tell yourself
subconsciously that I am NOT the kind of
person who follows throughs on my goals
and that's a problem so when you set an
immediate goal when you set something
that's going to happen today next week
next time I stand you have to go out and
make that happen
the big goal sure the big goal you're
never gonna you're never going to get
there you will never empty the ocean
with a ladle
but the things you set for yourself to
do tomorrow you better get out and do
them so be very careful about what your
short-term goals are because if you are
setting these short-term goals and you
don't follow through your you're
building a negative reinforcement loop
that you'll continue to doubt yourself
and you'll continue to set more goals
and never
who we're on the flip side if you set
these goals and then you do them
it creates endorphins it makes you feel
good about yourself then you set more
goals and you do them makes you believe
that you can do more goals and you you
develop the identity of when I set a
goal I follow through on them no matter
what I will do them I accomplish them
that's a great mindset to haves and
allow you to continue to build bigger
and bigger goals way number three is
model success again whenever I don't
know what to do whatever goals I don't
know what to set I always look at who
has done this before
somebody may have taken decades to
figure out how to solve a specific
problem I can learn from them and apply
immediately into my life or my business
and solve the problem that I'm faced
with right now and so to think that you
have to come up with every single
amazing I knew yourself is wrong and you
won't and this is what almost buried my
first company and I say that Bill Gates
saved my first company because I studied
his success and I applied it to my
business where before I've had to come
up with every single new idea myself now
we're not just copying from people we're
not just saying well I'm gonna do it
exactly the way Bill Gates did it or
Steve Jobs or Oprah Winfrey or Priyanka
Chopra it's not gonna be the exact path
but they could take you 80 90 % of the
way and then that last 10 20 percent you
have to customize to yourself but if
you're trying to do a hundred percent
brand new every single time it's gonna
take you a long time to figure out what
the right goals are and then the right
path to achieving it and so as soon as
you set a goal one of the things I love
doing is looking at who has already
solved this goal and what can I learn
from them how can I model their success
by starting videos on this channel
reading books doing interviews listen to
the podcast whatever it is to get me
closer to achieving my goal
[Music]
hey what's up a leave nation my name is
matthew from the trident lion channel
here to bring you tip number four
sacrifice unimportant activities now
think about this for yourself do some
self auditing ask yourselves in what
areas of my life
can i reallocate my time to be more
valuable now i remember several months
ago i was listening to best-selling
author tim ferriss his podcast and he
said something that was potent with
value
he was elaborating on the importance of
having a do not do list is very easy to
make a to-do list and check off some of
it kind of neglect some of the other
ones but by having a do not list it
forces you to cut out those unimportant
activities that you really don't want to
be doing every single day if you have
big goals if you have big ambitions
there's no reason why you have to spend
hours and hours hours a day on social
media or television just consuming
content now i'm sure many of us in the
belief nation do spend a lot of time on
the computer or on our phones or on
social media because we're entrepreneurs
and we believe in what we're doing and
we have to spread our message to impact
people and reach our clients and
customers in our audience but there's a
difference between content production
and content distribution and content
consumption now the unimportant
activities is going to be doing way too
much of the consuming and less of the
producing less of the hustling so if you
have goals and they're important to you
and they're priority to you make it a
point to establish your do not do list
sacrifice all those unimportant dumb
activities that are not going to bring
you any real value besides immediate
pleasure in the short term but in the
long term you'll experience suffering in
the suffering at first starts as that
monkey on your back that thing that you
got to get done or you really want to
get done but you're procrastinating on
and in the long term that suffering is a
form of regret now if that doesn't give
you enough spark to take action on your
goals then let's just ask gary vee how
he feels about regret
the biggest poison in us is regretted
it's poison
[Music]
wait number five is make your schedule
match this is one of the biggest things
that entrepreneurs have a problem with
they set these ambitious goals they set
these things that they want to do and
then you look at their schedule and they
don't have the time
laid out so that they can accomplish
those goals if you have goals for them
to happen you need to take action goals
don't just happen you have to take some
kind of action so are you taking the
action on a regular basis that will lead
to those goals of being accomplished
so what I'd everybody to do challenge
you to do right now look at your list of
goals look at the things that you want
to accomplish and then look at what your
week looks like next week look at the
tasks that have been lined out look at
how your time is being divided are the
activities that you are doing in your
calendar for the next week for the next
month do they map to you accomplishing
these goals do the specific activities
that you're doing on a regular basis if
you keep doing those regular activities
it'll mean these goals get accomplished
because if these are not matching up you
just have a dream you just have a vision
which is fantastic to be motivating but
if you're not doing the work you're
never going to accomplish the goal so
those things have to match when you get
inspired it's awesome when you're
modeling success it's amazing now you
have to make sure that your schedule
your calendar maps to your ambition way
number six is to get leverage this is
getting leverage over yourself because
it's so easy to stay where you are
because chances are you're comfortable
you're not happy it's not amazing
there's a lot of things that are wrong
in your lives and business that you may
want to change but you're not being
forced to change it's comfortable it's
okay
and the enemy of great is good the enemy
of great is not terrible the enemy of
great is good when you're good you're
good you know you don't wanna do the
work to change because change is a lot
of pain and so you're good and so you
just you might complain about it you
might take kind of small actions but
you're not really motivated to do it and
so you need to get leverage over
yourself you need to find out the why
the big reason why is is so important
that it has to happen right now I was
meeting with a woman last week who wants
to start her entrepreneurial journey and
she's had this goal for the past five
years to be an entrepreneur and she's
barely done any work on it because she
always feels like well tomorrow and that
this month next week you know there's
time I'll figure it out flash-forward
five years later still doing the same
thing still to the same position still
hasn't taken action on her dream and so
it's hard sometimes to get leverage in
the micro because you feel like tomorrow
I can get it done next week I can get it
done it's okay have enough time what you
need to do is imagine every day when
you're looking at your goals this is
what I want to accomplish and if I don't
do something today I'm gonna be here
another five years and another 10 years
in the exact same position that I'm in
right now makes a huge difference so
figuring out what your trigger point is
whether you know for me it's I imagine
myself on my deathbed looking back and
saying I wish I had done more I wish I'd
taken action here I wish I hadn't
slacked off it's also for me trying to
create legacy I want my grandkids to
watch this video I want to create
something every single day that I would
be proud to show my grandkids they look
at grandpa Evan made that's what I try
to do every single day if I if I haven't
done something today that I want my
grandkids to see I consider it a wasted
day that's leverage over myself figuring
out what the leverage is for you and
then reminding yourself of that on a
daily basis will help push you into
action and way number seven is to change
your environment a lot of times it's
hard to get psyched up to get ready to
do something right I don't wake up every
morning fired up ready to go yes amazing
this day is gonna crush I wake up and
I'm tired and the alarm went off and I'm
wiping my eyes and you know I'm
stumbling into my day but what helps me
is the habits in the routine and the
environment so there will be some days
where you need to force yourself through
the thought process by getting leverage
by thinking about your big goals by
thinking about you know you're gonna
regret not doing this all of that but to
do that every single day can be hard can
be taxing there'll be days where you
don't want to do it so the advantage of
having a fantastic environment is that
you don't have to do any work for it
right you create your environment once
and then automatically every single day
it triggers the behavior that you want I
was talking to a fan who was who stopped
by and wanted to say hi during filming
day and he was talking about the book he
just bought the top ten it was a success
and leaving it on his desk because every
day he looked at it in the faces
the cover was just a reminder for him to
be more successful that looking at the
book made him want to have more success
and so we put it in a prominent place
when he walked into his office you don't
have to think about that right if you
look at my home office you see the
pictures of Steve Jobs and how it shows
to my parents and AP Giannini and Kanye
up on the wall I walk into that place
and it can't help but feel inspired that
I need to do something bigger today and
so I can go from a place of being super
tired and not having enough sleep on
some days and low energy too I gotta
make today count I got these people
staring me down my environment is
building me up and so think about you
what triggers you maybe it's listening
to a podcast or watching the video or
having a book on the table or putting
pictures on the wall like what is the
thing that gets you feeling fire it up
and then put that into your environment
so it just happens automatically instead
of you having to every single morning
get yourself primed and pumped for
success so those are my tips on the 7
changes you need to make to achieve your
goals I'd love to know from you which
one struck you the most which one are
you going to immediately apply somehow
into your life or business did I miss an
8 9 10 that you want to add to the list
leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
raise your standard not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details